becky is so wonderful to connect with
you first thing first how are you doing
i'm doing so good thank god i'm just
here in l.a it's
holiday time i'm launching my talk show
it's it's all kinds of good stuff going
i'm good you know watching you you're
like this person that is on this ramp of
success and just keeps going and going
and going and here you are again with
your new show face to face uh with becky
g which is an amazing name what does it
mean for you to now have this platform
oh my goodness well i'm glad it looks
like this because behind me that's a lot
of this
um
i am so blessed honestly to have had
so many of the opportunities and
experiences that i've had throughout my
years of doing this and it's even weird
saying years because i'm obviously a
baby um so i didn't i didn't think i'd
be a host of my own talk show this early
on in my career but i think that's what
makes it so special because i have no
idea what i'm doing
um and and that's a point of view that
maybe we haven't really seen much you
know when it comes to talk shows and
face to face with becky g and even the
name you know i i came up with the name
and i was like guys this is it like it's
just these face-to-face conversations
with dear friends of mine with people
that i'm meeting sometimes for the first
time
um and in creating these safe spaces
creating a community where we can have
these safe conversations about things
that are very important to our
communities diversity and representation
um
self-discovery mental health um
identity crisis you know all kinds of
things that i think is important for us
to talk about because a lot of times
we're looked at like oh you know you're
young you'll figure it out and it's like
no no like i'm really going through some
stuff right now and i really want to
find you know a space where i can
acknowledge and talk about these things
yeah
and so what was a convincing point for
you to say this is the time for me to
host like you said you're young you
still have a lot to do and what was it
because this is a lot of work it's not
easy it is it is a lot of work i'm also
an executive producer on the show and it
is
a lot of responsibility a lot of
preparation um and it's not about me
which is actually kind of nice um it's
about our guests it's about the the the
story you know the story that they have
to share and uh as a host i do i think
bring my own point of view i think in
order to
invite people to be so courageous and
share their own stories sometimes you
have to share a little bit too and so
throughout this show i'll also be
sharing personal things about my journey
um with my you know guests and and our
audience but
i guess we were just gonna have to tune
in to to see i think the the challenge
in it all was
um not keeping it you know authentic
because that came very easy for everyone
i think the challenge was how do you
condense all of this into a digestible
small
you know
couple minute situation for people
because we we would get so deep into
conversation i mean the stuff that that
my my audience is gonna gonna get to
experience with us is very special very
special
is there any way or anything you would
not wanna talk about because you just
said you have to bring your own
experience to make that connection when
you're sitting down with somebody is
there a place that you have decided for
yourself that you will not open up to
yeah i mean i think there's a lot of
things that i've been a very open book
about you know my own mental health uh
journey um
i guess something that's very relevant
to where i am today is is embarking on
that journey of self-discovery i started
in this industry at such a young age and
it came with a lot of pressure to have
all the answers you know you're the
youngest person in the room and you
still have to bring solutions to a lot
of problems
that is not normal for someone your age
to be dealing with and so
i'm now you know next year i'll be
turning a quarter of whatever life is
and 25 is interesting because i remember
turning 22 and thinking wow i'm so grown
and i know exactly where i am in my life
you got a long way to go and now i'm
like who the hell am i i don't even know
what i want to eat for dinner tonight um
i thought i knew how to cook but
apparently not and so it's kind of like
embracing this uh place where i don't
really know i don't really know anything
and i think it's it's a beautiful space
to be in because it's an opportunity for
growth it's an opportunity for learning
and so that's kind of what face to face
is like i said i have no clue what i'm
doing but
um i learned i learned so much from from
everyone who gets to sit on that couch
and and just how brave and courageous
they are to to share and be their true
authentic self you know um
it's nice it's refreshing
and it's interesting you're saying that
because like
you know what you're doing you know what
you're doing with this show so you know
you're going in with an idea of what
this show has to be uh what have you
learned about yourself through this
process
that
i really want to rest in order to uh in
order to res uh what is the word i guess
um
fuel anything yeah in order to be able
to receive i need to rest and as like an
artist i think you know it's very easy
and especially to like women of like
ethnic cultures we're constantly giving
we're just giving giving giving giving
giving ideas love care compassion
empathy to everything and everyone
except ourselves
and so um it was really special working
on this project because i was able to
give so much in a way that i had never
gotten to before
and i learned so much from everyone that
was coming in that i was like wow maybe
i need to like take some of their advice
and like
oh everyone was talking about this thing
called rest and like how important it is
and i was like
maybe that's what like i dedicate some
time to i guess because i've never not
been working i've never helped
so okay so you're a singer you write
your music you are
entrepreneur what am i missing actress
you know you're doing so much so what do
you do for fun
uh sleep i eat i
yeah it's i'd i
have yet and that's i guess on the list
of like personal goals um i have yet to
really
like see the world you know i and i
that's so wild because obviously i've
gotten to see the world through a lens
of like a superstar or whatever and
travel and tour and perform in front of
amazing fans and sing songs and then
sing it back to you but
you'd be surprised that after you're in
front of thousands and thousands of
people you go back to your hotel room
and you're alone and
you see more of a city through the car
and the airport and
more of your hotel in the room service
menu then you get to go walking around a
city because of a demanding itinerary
and schedule or because you haven't
gotten time to sleep
and so like i look forward to you know
being able to like travel the world one
day but not for work like i look forward
to getting to just like live in my own
home
for a consecutive amount of time without
having to be like okay i'm preparing for
tour i'm preparing for this big film you
know
so i think that's those are the things
that i haven't gotten to yet those are
the good the good things the other good
things you would like to go
um i would love it's fine i went to
uh fashion week uh in milan for the
first time and everyone was like how was
italy and i was like i didn't really get
to see it i want to go back so i think
like italy is like somewhere that i
really love to visit um as like a
tourist like for fun or as a local i
guess you could say
um
i would also love to go to places like
japan like i've never i've never been to
japan before that would be super cool
so yeah i guess wherever the wind takes
me wherever i can find a good window to
see these places
i can't wait for you to travel i mean
right after this maybe you'll take that
break uh you have some incredible guests
on your show who can we expect
yes well our first episode is available
november 9th and our first guest is demi
lovato and they are someone who is just
so special to me has been throughout my
career but also on a personal note and
if you watch the episode you will see
why
um
we also invite you know individuals like
diego boneta isabella merced rome flynn
um
we also had cheeky's like i mean so many
incredible incredible people who have
amazing resumes and some even at
incredible young ages but getting to
know the human being behind all of the
accomplishments and the success
those stories were the ones that were
the most fascinating for me and so
i think a lot of people will leave
inspired for sure and we have games too
we play some really fun games like at
the end
um some that i wasn't even prepared for
to be honest so it gets really funny it
gets really funny i watched one of your
clips with demi lovato and you say you
don't like the word role model you like
the word real model so who is your real
model
i think we're seeing more and more real
models today i actually you know had the
opportunity to tell demi themselves that
i think they are
a great role model you know the
difference between a role model and a
real model is i think you know although
role models started with a really great
intention because we need someone good
to look up to
the idea that good is only good if you
are perfect if you have all the answers
and have it all figured out i just don't
think that our youth really benefits
from that today you know i grew up in a
generation where i only saw my favorite
icons on a red carpet on stage in in in
glitz and glamour
now we get to see our you know favorite
artists or our favorite actors in the
morning when they wake up you know on on
live and without a filter or what it
looks like when they spend time with
their family and they're not working
um and i think that is showing that
they're a role model you know that they
are a real person that there's a human
being behind
all of those things and
it's a generation where i think you
don't have to be a pop star to know what
the pressures are to look a certain way
to act a certain way to dress a certain
way to speak a certain way and so when
you see someone being so real and honest
about not having it all together and not
having it all figured out it's
refreshing and it's it's just um it's
good it's good i think it's it's a good
thing we need more real models for sure
yeah it's so much healthier right it's
just you actually see that people are
real uh will you have christina aguilera
part of the show i mean you guys just
wrote the song the queen
i love the universe i mean how great
would that be incredible oh my god so i
met her actually uh for the first time
um at the release party of the song we
had gotten to speak obviously doing the
song but never in person so i was
freaking out super fangirl moment um and
say to her
yeah i mean we i mean we had this
awesome conversation like about the song
about you know even singing in spanish
it's amazing you know i i
reminded everyone you know christina was
singing in spanish before it was popular
um
one of the first cds i ever bought was a
christina aguilera cd that had her album
in english and if you flipped it over
you can listen to the same exact album
in spanish
and that inspired me so much because i
realized wow i can do both i don't have
to choose you know and and and today we
have families muchachas and i get to be
a part of it it just felt like such a
full circle moment for me and she's just
such an incredible woman you know
overall like an amazing mother an
amazing artist who has continued to just
keep killing it throughout all of this
um
you know shifts and changes that come in
an industry like the one we work in
she's just stayed true and has only
gotten more amazing as like the years
have gone by so
yeah i can preach about how amazing
christina aguilera is all day and i
would love to have her uh for a
face-to-face conversation on our talk
show yeah it's a wicked song i
absolutely love it so good who is the
ultimate guest you want on your show
oh
who is the ultimate guest i think
everyone has something that's so unique
to like share that i don't know if
there's like the ultimate guest i mean
there must be someone you just want to
sit down and say hey let's talk
yeah i mean i guess what's really cool
is like you know most times you you see
a host and and they they they come off
as this like very seasoned very poised
uh know exactly what they're doing and
like me like there's a fan girl that
exists in me that geeks out over like
like i was like that with demi even like
i literally told them afterwards i was
like i still can't believe that you did
this like what um so i think that it
would be really funny to see the me that
doesn't know what i'm doing uh have a
face-to-face conversation with someone
like jlo because i'm the biggest halo
fan too
um so
yeah
just looking
that would be so awesome so with all of
that everything that's gone into your
life at this young age how do you define
success for yourself
i think success is it's kind of like
music tasted subjective you know like i
can think like tupac is the greatest
rapper of all time and you can be like
absolutely not
um i think for me success isn't it's not
a number in your bank account it's not a
number of streams followers views to me
there's success in even the smallest of
things like waking up in the morning
to me there's success in being able to
you know provide for myself
you know growing up in a culture where a
woman had to be dependent on another
person specifically a man to
to be successful in life to have nice
things to dream even to own a house all
of those things
it feels really good for me to be able
to be in a position to not just help
myself but also help others within my
family you know provide for my family
provide for my community and in a sense
even um
i think to to be successful is to be a
good person like there's just a lot of
success that comes with like being a
good person um because you're not
you're not it's it's not self-motivated
you know what i mean like it literally
like anything could happen in life and
if i'm around good people
like i'm chilling i'm so good so yeah i
think that's what success is to me
it's beyond any of the
the really cool things that you know are
on my resume or whatever
your mom must be so proud of you my
goodness she's my best friend and yes
she is um
i think very proud but also like you
know she sees she sees all of the the
not so pretty things of
of what i've gone through and what i
continue to experience behind closed
doors and
there's also been times where she's told
me you know i'm proud of you without any
of this you don't have to
you don't have to pick up a microphone
ever again in your life you don't have
to
you just you don't have to you come from
nothing you're fine with nothing mama
and i think that that's what's kept me
going actually you know is is that
that grounding that person um that
family reminding you that this is all
just a bonus like enjoy the ride it's
awesome like one day like the awards
aren't gonna you know hold me close at
night they're not gonna cuddle with me
when i'm sad so it's like the good
people part is is very important for
sure
well we're gonna be watching your ride
you are absolutely amazing and and i
wish you so much luck in everything you
do and hopefully go on that trip one day
soon i know it's a break
okay i will i'm gonna start putting a
little bit more more effort there for
sure i'm going to do the same i'm to do
the same we'll we'll just call it true
so i don't both make sure it happens for
both of us
congratulations i can't wait to watch
your episodes thank you so much for
chatting with us
thank you so much for your time i really
appreciate it
you